yo it's crazy because when you have a
record like coming in hot which is like
uh
how long after the song came out did it
like really start to pick up
on like tik tok because i felt like it
wasn't right away right right well
amongst our my core fan base like it did
really well
and then it was 2018. i i did it to go
on tour me and la craig went on tour
did it when on tour uh it did great and
then it died off for a second and then
um
steph curry started using it and then it
got used in like a under armour
commercial or something like that
then they went to the finals then the
finals used it so then they had another
pick up then it died down
then will smith used it to announce that
he was on tick-tock
and then it has a moment so it just has
all these waves of light influencers and
then kim kardashian posts with it then
has another uptick and
that's the thing we live in an era of
land mines not rocket ships you know
what i'm saying so it's like a record
could be sitting around and someone
stumbles on it uses it oh it's crazy
it's crazy yeah
you know songs from like 2014 going
crazy you're like yeah i was thinking
like that the wiz and ty dolla sign song
something new was like
what was that like 2017 and then like
2020 went crazy just went crazy
off of a like it's it's wild yeah and
you got a plaque off that record right
yeah we just got a another goal
it's tight man i mean for being it's an
independent label and no radio play to
be able to have a couple plaques you
know from what we do that's huge man
it's dope man it's really shout out to
the the fans who support us like they
come out for real you know nice that's
uh i think
i know how hard it is to get a [ __ ]
plaque yeah yeah
especially
on an independent label you know what
i'm saying you know we don't we don't um
yeah like we've never
ever played radio
ever yeah i was gonna ask did you guys
ever consider like bringing on someone
to help you work that record
to radio um well so at the at the time
lecrae
up did like an up deal with colombia so
he did the records with ty dolla signing
all that and they didn't remember radio
with that
um so at the time he was with them and
uh
i think that was something that was in
consideration is like upcycling through
them so that they could run it
but basically from what i understand is
like nobody wants to
put their neck on the line at the label
for
a record
because if it doesn't work then it
basically cost them their job so
i just don't think there was enough
people that believed in it to to push
the bus i think like i think that record
could like i think astronaut in the
ocean song was like top ten at radio
and it was just
not as tight as your song
it was like a very novel novelty like
tick-tock record yeah but that went
crazy yeah crazy
and yeah absolutely what's dope about
what you're doing is like you got you
had one of those but like you have
you could tour
you have like for sure for sure a
built-in like real following right cause
we've been at it you know before that
record and
so and i've had plaques before that so
it's like
you know we we've proven that we do this
you know i'm saying